il fait donc de l'ironie sur ce max en
russe
géopolitique il y aura t-il de meilleur
que d'autres on attend avant avec son
sur le compte telegram rt France et
place en face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pourrons parler Joël députée
européenne
en direct avec nous avons depuis Thomas
membres du Parlement de l'Union
Populaire Bonsoir Thomas porte merci
d'être avec nous donc on vient
d'entendre Macron qui appelle les
Européens être
nationaliste
je crois que je crois que c'est Emmanuel
Macron il y a il y a un peu de
maladresse et tous les mots sont bien
choisi et une femme de 1 ans mais qui a
regardé la situation sanitaire dans un
pays comme la France on a donné des
milliards à un groupe comme ça non fille
qui n'a pas été capable de trouver le
vaccin donc le son c'est un peu c'est un
peu ridicule mais je crois que Emmanuel
Macron plutôt que de Cernay des bons. Il
ferait mieux de se mobiliser pour ce que
nous nous demandons depuis des mois
salaire la levée des brevets tu connais
rien qui revient qui vient d'Afrique du
Sud ou simplement 25 % de la population
et vacciné donc l'urgence elle est à
lever les brevets et pas à distiller les
petites phrases parce que c'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
les meilleures chansons du monde parce
que nous sommes
votre réaction justement en tant que
député européen ça vous étonnez
nous d'Emmanuel Macron plus rien ne
m'étonne honnêtement on est un petit peu
au bout de deux d'une certaine forme de
vraiment de pardon le terme et de
médiocrité pour deux raisons la première
c'est que tous les vaccins entre
guillemets qui ont été mis sur le marché
européen
à quelque chose près des thérapies
géniques sur fin qui a pu être distribué
largement moderne ne sont pas des
vaccins contrairement aux sinopharm que
les vaccins et Rennes
quand on a refusé refuser de faire
l'expérimentation telle qu'elle doit
être fait au niveau de Lima ou au niveau
des pays je rappelle une chose c'est
concernant le soutenir que le sinopharm
leur méthodologie de production n'oblige
pas à passer par les mains que ensuite
il est LAVAL de l' OMS pourquoi pas en
tout état de cause cela n'a pas été fait
dans aucun sens ni pour dire que ça
marche ni pour dire que ça ne marche pas
c'est positivement insupportable c'était
particulièrement insupportable on va
dire au début de l'année 2021 quand il
n'y avait pas encore assez de vaccin à
tout le moins pour le rock il y en aura
bien entendu pas encore assez pour le
reste du monde et quand on est le
président d'un pays où le ministre de
l'Intérieur en mars 2020 a refusé a
refusé de déclencher la cellule de crise
nécessaire pour démarrer le bon prix de
protection des Français je crois qu'on
évite de donner des leçons aux autres
pays est particulièrement des pays qui
ont pris la responsabilité je pense en
particulier en droit à tort ou à raison
c'est la suite qui nous dira il y en a
pas de leçon à donner quand soi-même on
a pas permis de protéger sa population
alors petit retour en arrière avec la
revue scientifique très reconnu recette
pour la revue médicale
91,6 pourcents contre les formes
automatiques du du covid-19
la moindre chance
donc ses études quand même extrêmement
sérieuse et en cours
dire que voilà il est pas
mal mais moi je pense qu'il y a
aujourd'hui
absolument transparent et l'urgence elle
est pas emmener la guerre sur les
vaccins entre le vaccin REPEVAX en
français qu'on a pas et qu'on espère
avoir et les vacances d'autres pays je
crois que je l'ai dit tout à l'heure on
a une situation on a besoin de vacciner
massivement les populations qui ne sont
pas aujourd'hui vacciné et si on veut
pas avoir des variant qui reviennent
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui BPI on a
pas de vaccination il faut lever les
volets on a le président République qui
nous a dit il y a quelques mois je suis
content parce que il voulait protéger de
certains d'intérêt financier ils
arrêteront pédaler en disant je m'engage
à ce qu'on enlève les brevets mais
aujourd'hui c'est toujours pas levé on a
des pays qui a été en capacité de
produire c'est laquelle la si on décide
de lever et je termine sur un chiffre on
a une enquête qui a révélé qui avait
quasiment 243 doses pour 100 habitants
dans les pays des revenus et c'est assez
important dans les pays à faible revenu
donc sans vaccination mondiale
aujourd'hui on ne sortira pas de se
parler on va regarder
poids lourd donc vous venez par et on
apporte la fine l'Argentine Iran le
Mexique le Pakistan encore les
Philippines les Émirats au Venezuela ça
veut dire quoi en gros
le tri la différence entre certains pays
écouter la différence l'Union européenne
a commencé à le faire en envoyer en dans
le grand plan Kovacs en envoyant tous
les vaccins Astra Zeneca que l'Europe
n'a pas voulu donc pardon il n'y a
absolument là encore Emmanuel Macron
serait bien de rester discret et
s'occuper très sérieusement de ce qui se
passe en France et de la réalité de ces
épidémie parce que je crois qu'il serait
plus sage que l'on parle de ses épidémie
j'en ai à la 5e vague mais à chaque fois
ce sont des virus non pas à part entière
ils sont affiliés les uns aux autres
mais on voit bien que ce qui marchait à
9192 ou 95 pourcents sur le sur le virus
original marche de moins en moins bien
et je vous rappelle d'ailleurs que la
certification puisque elle a eu lieu ces
jours-ci à l'Union européenne se fait
avec la demande expresse que les
producteurs de vaccin de processus ARN
messager messager passe à partir de
modélisation des future épidémie
exactement comment c'est pour la grippe
tous les ans depuis maintenant des
dizaines d'années à partir des souches
qui viennent toujours d'ailleurs d'Asie
c'est toujours d'est en ouest on fait
une modélisation à partir des souches
hautement probable pour pouvoir mettre
sur le marché en Europe occidentale des
vaccin pour la grippe qui ne fois sur
dix marche bien et puis des fois il y a
un échappement parce que la modélisation
n'est pas adapté et cette année-là on
dit qu'il y a eu une mauvaise grippe
mais il est urgent de travailler sur les
modélisation c'est ce que l'Europe a
demandé enfin nous avons énormément de
retard alors après on
sait déjà que
lorsque on aura
déjà
fabrication
de
laboratoire
sur énormément de laboratoire
remarquable je pense en particulier en
France de nombre labo qui ont fermé
leurs portes après ils ont disparu en
temps quand ils sont tous devenus
sous-traitant ici avec ses sous-traitant
on appuie sur 55 sites le fabriquer ses
5 vaccins européen donc monsieur Macron
véritablement n'as vraiment pas à
ironisé comme ça c'est pas le moment on
peut trouver des solutions soit levé les
brevets mais je ne suis pas énervé
mentation pour vous dire que ce n'est
pas utile puisque les prix au niveau des
États aux États de faire des produits et
à la propriété intellectuelle voilà
c'est vraiment pas le moment
sur
le dos de son vaccin de production en
conjointe concrètement pékin plus que le
dispositif
s'il faut changer les choses quand il
prendra la tête de l'Europe
tout à l'heure
on a parlé
on est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
et si on veut sortir de la situation
dans laquelle se trouve la planète
aujourd'hui il faudra bien revenir c'est
logique libérale et de profiter
aujourd'hui je prends de la
marchandisation sur la santé
inégale dans le monde a les pays riches
organise une campagne 3e dos et
seulement 5 % de la population des pays
en voie de développement a reçu pour
savoir une première dose clairement la
doit jouer un rôle
dans la mesure où effectivement nous
avons affaire à un virus mais moi je
dirais plutôt des virus des virus que
l'on pourrait peut-être arrêter par la
vaccination tout à fait d'accord pour
dire qu'il faut que des efforts soient
faits charge aux et à sa charge
l'Union européenne et a des grandes
quantités de trouver des solutions pour
que la majorité de la planète soit
protégé sauf que je ne suis pas tout à
fait sûr que ça se passe comme ça et que
il y a peut-être d'autres mesures à
prendre que deux ne parlait que de
vaccination nous avons bien vu que de la
même façon que l'on n'a pas souhaité
évaluer le tout nique et sa demande a
été déposé en mars 2021 à l'Union
européenne auprès de lui il y a toujours
pas de réponse à ce que je sache l'OM S
ça fait pareil il faut absolument faire
une expérimentation de tout ce qui se
présente
comme la pleurote univers mec qui nous
où d'autres produits dans ton a pas
souhaité aller jusqu'au bout des
expérimentations tout ça pour mettre
dans l'impasse tout d'une vaccination
qui est manifestement très imparfaite à
la fois dans le temps parce que vacciné
une impasse un où il y a de l'argent ou
une autre pathologie ou même une crise
d'hiver en en Europe occidentale c'est
une chose vacciner la planète entière
c'en est une autre il faut quand même
avoir la notion des échelles et des
ligne de production les ligne de
production fonctionner à partir du mois
de mai le peu qu'on avait entre décembre
et avril était très insuffisants ne
serait-ce que pour l'Europe et à ce
propos la ce qui nous a été proposée
Emmanuel Macron ne l'a pas accepté
peut-être que certaines personnes n'ont
pas bénéficier de ce soit là en temps
utile
pourquoi pardonnez-moi pourquoi selon
vous
et comme vous le dites
je crois qu'il y a des réponses
multiples et certaines peuvent
s'entendre au titre de la recherche
nécessaire et du temps nécessaire pour
des développements 2 phase 1 2 ou 3 mais
je crois aussi quand même qui a eu
beaucoup de rétention d'information
vivent dans une période et en peux me
donner tort à personne et raison à
personne il est vrai que rien est clair
tout est opaque moi-même vu les contrats
des vaccins il est normal que le temps
de son été mis sur la table des le mois
de janvier 2020 et qu'à ce jour sortie
des vaccins on a pratiquement aucune
autre possibilité on voit apparaître
pour certains stade de la maladie mais
pas en prévention mais pas pour les cas
contact on a aucune alternative soit
accepté avec les Somni sur la table que
ce soit parlera mais que ce soit aussi
par la barda américaine qui a largement
cofinancé les vaccins européen que ce
soit aux Indes en Inde que ce soit en
Chine et sont mis sur la table de vrai 2
ans et demi parce que l'épidémie a
commencé en 2019 voilà on devrait en
être ailleurs il y a beaucoup de pas si
tu es véritablement au lieu de faire de
l'ironie Monsieur Macron devrait taper
sur la table demander à Franck connaître
l'origine de ce virus tant qu'on ne
connaît pas les lire le bouddhisme
véritablement d'où il vient on peut pas
être hyper efficace on avance un peu par
à l'aveugle sommes tout et maintenant
par empirisme il faut absolument dégager
d'autres possibilités de traitement
prévention au niveau des cas comptable
et bien entendu quand tu es casse sont
avérés est en réanimation où nous sommes
d'ailleurs de mieux en mieux former et
on nous avons de la
porte de la fin vous êtes d'accord il y
a une hostie Copa si tu es rétention
d'informations
parce que les Européens ont dû se battre
pour avoir
aujourd'hui
aussi revenir raison garder moi je pense
que Emmanuel Macron devrais rendre les
têtes aujourd'hui gratuit on peut pas
accepter que des personnes paye à chaque
fois 40 € car ils ne sont pas vacciné
pour faire un test on va approcher les
fin d'année on doit pouvoir permettre
aux uns aux autres de se tester pour
diminuer la circulation du virus qui
aujourd'hui reprends avec une force
absolument impressionnante merci en tout
cas
on dirait
merci à vous deux